today we're going to be speaking with
tim jackson who's an ecological
economist professor and also author of
the book post growth life after
capitalism it's so great to have you on
i appreciate it
it's a it's a pleasure to be here david
so let's start with something that to a
social democrat like me
uh is still something that is in the
back of my mind which is that we are on
a planet that has some maximum capacity
in terms of resources in terms of
population carrying capacity etc
our economies are based on
a little bit of inflation is good and
where that inflation comes from is the
expectation that there will be more
productivity in the future than there is
today and
gdp
has to continue going up or we consider
that we're in a recession
structurally at some point that becomes
a problem right is that a sound place to
start the conversation
yeah i think it is a sound place to
start the conversation david and it's
definitely where i start as well um and
and it's surprising
it's surprisingly easy to kind of make
that argument you know to to ordinary
people in the streets in a way we're
living on a finite planet the economy is
supposed to expand
forever we're told by economists surely
at some point you know
expanding economy into finite planet
doesn't go
so so what nurse is going on and and
um
what's surprising i think is that
that's a difficult proposition for
politicians of any color i would say
to really take seriously or to know what
to do anything about um
and and economists typically i would
have to say tend to think that uh
the economy is is about money it's not
necessarily about stuff
um and so if we're clever enough with
our technology we can sort of get
ourselves off the hook
and work our way round all of these
resource limits and i suppose
you know that's an argument right and so
one of the arguments that's frequently
made is
while what you're saying is true at this
point it's basically theoretical in the
sense that it's very far out and you
know a hundred years ago nobody could
have predicted exactly the way things
are today if we're talking thousands or
tens of thousands of years from now
things will be so structurally different
that this is at minimum going to at in
the best case it will resolve itself in
the worst case we'll have the tools with
which to deal with it by the time it's
really a problem but that doesn't really
seem satisfying as as
an ecological answer
well i think i think where it falls down
too
is that that might be true for some
kinds of resources that we might run out
of but actually we're already running
out of what you could call ecological
space you know we're running out of
climate stability we're running out of
the other species on the planet that are
being decimated because of human
activity we're running out of
clean water and clean air and clean
oceans and and that running out is
actually something that's happening
right now i mean the evidence on that is
alarming just the simply the climate
change uh evidence what what's faced you
know the west coast in terms of heat and
the east coast in terms of of flooding
and europe in terms of flooding and
australia in terms of heat almost
everywhere you look on the planet you
know we're seeing these extreme weather
conditions which suggest that
you know somehow that far out scenario
that expanding economy meets the limits
of the planet actually isn't that far
out after all it's kind of right here on
our doorstep
one of the um
issues i guess that economists are
confronted with within this kind of
conversation within this paradigm is
there are certain aspects of how we
think about an economy that are kind of
taken for granted i mentioned already if
gdp isn't growing this is a country that
is stagnating or in a recession in a
decline that's one aspect of this
debt and deficit and how that relates to
how
a country is doing is is a big piece of
this how would those metrics
have to be completely rethought under
the umbrella and framework that you
propose
well i think i think in a way you know
gdp was never a very good metric i mean
one of the things i do in the book is go
back to the words of of of robert
kennedy speaking in 1968 53 years ago
where actually he was a you know
prominent politician prepared to
acknowledge the limits of this measure
of the gdp and say look it measures um
you know
everything
except that which makes life worthwhile
he said but it also it misses out the
damage we're causing to the planet it
doesn't include
the positive things that people do for
free in their own homes it's just not a
very good measure of our well-being and
and so so in a sense you know the answer
to your question well let's start with
some better measures of what really
matters and some of those measures you
know like our
our sense of well-being and our sense of
purpose and so on could be could be
measures which are very unfamiliar to
politicians and that's a little bit of a
challenge but others of them are really
quite simple like you know not measuring
for example how much we are degrading
our capital assets in the economy itself
is something that the gdp is is um
notorious for for for failing to do
and and not putting any sort of sense of
cost on um on the damage that we're
causing to
to the environment and not putting any
sort of value on the
work that people do in their own homes
all of these things actually and there
are very very good uh
attempts to improve that measure of the
gdp but you could almost say at this
point in time
almost any distance towards measuring
something more meaningful than the gdp
would be a step forwards because it's
just not a very good measure of progress
it's not a very good measure of human
progress in society so in terms of some
of those things
the universal basic income movement
which has different names proposes
itself as a way to put value to that
which is done in the home for example or
that which an economy may not currently
value uh carbon carbon taxes would be a
way in which we might put a monetary
value on the degradation or of the
environment or the pollution that that's
released et cetera
is that thinking too small still or are
those good ideas good steps no they are
very good ideas and some you know in
some ways something like universal basic
income is and i think when you know one
of the architects of the universal basic
income andre gortz talking about it
first
or or talking about it seriously in the
1960s he wasn't the first person to talk
about it but but what he sort of said
was it's a sort of stealth concept
because by changing our relationship to
the way that we earn money and by
changing our relationship to the way
that we work it enables us to think in
massively creative ways about all the
valuable things that are happening in
society like you know kind of
volunteering in our community and the
free work that happens in the home and
looking after our elderly and looking
after our kids and it allows us to put a
value on those things which
in the
purely capitalist system in the system
of the market if you like just don't
have that value on them so i you know
i'm in favor of those but i still think
i mean to answer your question
i would say they are tools in a toolbox
um and
the the difficulty sometimes in
implementing those tools using those
tools is that the architects of the
system uh
don't allow them to be used so the
example of ecological taxation for
example we talked about for decades and
yet it's really hard to implement
because of the politics of a
growth-based economy well that that's
where i was going to go next which is
when we talk about you know convincing
people getting people on board etc
it seems that two four and six year
political terms in in you know a variety
of different countries
are completely mismatched
with the timeline and priorities that
are required to deal with these issues
where a lot of these things
are longer term projects and if your
next election is in two years or four or
six it just seems to be fundamentally at
odds with the time skills that we're
talking about to actually make some of
these structural changes
it it is at odds in many ways and i
think you know that's not the only thing
that's wrong with the political system
because the other thing that's wrong is
it becomes
in some sense because of the way
in which political parties become funded
uh they end up being a sort of apologist
for the status quo of defending invested
interests and that sometimes stands in
the way of them
uh representing the interests of the
poorest in society the most vulnerable
in society including of course the other
species we share the planet with so you
we do have to think much more seriously
i think about you know the role of of
governance and the role of power
within government and and think about
that as you're suggesting in with a much
longer term view
and again there are some interesting
initiatives there um that in hungary
there's something called the ombudsman
for future generations a kind of
representative of people who are coming
way down the line from the future and
are not represented by the democracy of
the day and that's been taken up in
wales in the uk
um
but with a future generations act
and there's so this initiative in fact
to change the way that government works
to bring the future into our
decision-making in the present is a
really important part of of thinking
about how we address those long-term
issues certainly part of this would also
be more citizens
demanding these things of elected
officials
and there are a lot of
sort of
bullet points that are often repeated by
those who don't want to take these
issues more seriously about how such
structural change would impact our
day-to-day lives things about
you know you might only be able to have
small cars in the united states or
gas might be twenty dollars a gallon or
you might not be able to use your air
conditioning whenever you want or really
a lot of this day-to-day stuff
um
at the personal level
what would a paradigm shift the likes of
which you propose really mean for
individuals
yeah that's a really good question i
mean my work over over
more than three decades now has been
really working in policy and it's been
about you know suggesting the kinds of
economic policies that would that would
address some of these issues and in fact
just over 10 years 12 years ago the
previous book that uh that i wrote was
called prosperity without growth it was
written for policymakers it had all of
these wonderful ideas you know like
ecological tax reform universal basic
income different ways of valuing the
environment different ways of measuring
well-being it had all that stuff in it
um almost like a you know kind of
shopping list for what politicians could
do on monday if they really cared about
this issue right and it's been
fascinating to see that not happen
and and it you know it doesn't happen
for all sorts of reasons vested interest
short political time scales that we
talked about but also that fear
within politics that the electorate will
not stand for this kind of change you
know they that it's a it's a hard tough
place to be in which our lives will
become
uh less comfortable more arduous and so
on and so forth so there's a kind of
language of fear that populates this
debate
and in a way what i was trying to do in
post-grades was to say that's a mistake
you know the fear that we should have
actually
is of an economy that doesn't respect
the environment that doesn't respect
the value of human labor in our lives
that doesn't value these things properly
at all and that is driving us towards
you know a divided
um
world in which our environmental
resources are being degraded at a rate
we can't we can't cope with anymore
that's where dystopia lies and so the
postgres is really about looking for
where
an escape route from dystopia might
exist and i you know i think that that's
led me across philosophy it's led me
across psychology it's led me across
politics and and and indeed you know
moral thinking thinking about about the
ethics of our world and the thing that
leaps out at me i think most clearly
from that is that this
the potential for
for human development for human progress
outside of this very materialistic
consumer-based
growth-driven economy that we've
inherited
is huge it's massive because at the end
of the day um you know the kind of world
in which i think we thrive
is one in which our relationships are
strong in which our community feels
secure a world in which our work is not
just you know good in terms of income
and keeping us going but it's meaningful
as it has purpose for us and that and
that sense actually of living in a world
in which there is hope for the future
because we're taking those environmental
limits seriously is a tremendously
creative place and i've been fascinated
in particular by ideas um from within
psychology which sort of suggests that
actually
somehow materialism and the comfort of
consumerism
stand in the way of us um making real
human progress they stand in the way of
us developing skills because because we
come to become too lazy they stand in
the way of us developing active active
lives because we can't become too
comfortable and and sit around eating
too much and being comfortable and being
comfortable is wonderful you know don't
get me wrong i'm not knocking being
comfortable but there's a sense in which
being outside of that comfort zone takes
us to our true potential as human beings
where we learn those skills where we
engage in activities that give us
satisfaction where we feel as though
we're embodied in a world in which we
have meaning and purpose and in which
there is hope for the future and to me
therefore you know where i came out of
that exploration is really that this
post-growth world is a is a richer place
to be
not necessarily in terms of money
definitely not necessarily in terms of
material possessions but in terms of our
capabilities to live truly
uh fulfilling lives as human beings and
to return to ourselves that sense of
hope in the future yep and of course the
challenges in the midst of consumer
culture that bombards people it's
getting people to even be open to the
idea that that may actually be richer
and more fulfilling certainly an uphill
battle uh the book is i think
yeah no just on that point david i mean
i think that's true
and yet there are a million places to
start with that right you know how how
we how we educate our kids how we think
about our own progression through life
what decisions we make about where we
invest our money and our time all of
those are places to start so although
you know there are a lot as you say
there are lots of obstacles to that to
making those kinds of choices there are
also
there's a myriad of opportunities for
making them as well
well said well said uh the book is
post-growth life after capitalism we've
been speaking with tim jackson i so
appreciate your time today
it's been a pleasure david